NARRATOR: It's the greatest
aviation mystery of all time.
PILOT: Malaysia 370 contact
Ho Chi Minh on 120.9 Good night.
NARRATOR: How can a Boeing
777 with 239 people on board
simply vanish without a trace?
The answer lies somewhere at
the bottom of the Indian Ocean.
Imagine if we could empty the
oceans, letting the water drain
away to reveal the secrets
of the sea floor.
Now we can.
Using the latest underwater
scanning technology,
piercing the deep oceans,
and turning accurate
data into 3D images.
This time, with unique access
to the official investigation,
key mysteries
of Malaysia Airlines 370.
What lessons lie amid the wrecs
of previous air disasters?
Can Cold War technology extract
vital clues from the deep ocea?
And if the plane is found,
what secrets could lie hidden
in the tangled wreckage?
March the 8th 2014,
Malaysia Airlines flight
370 departs Kuala Lumpur,
on a six-hour flight to Beijin.
NARRATOR: As the Boeing 777
enters Vietnamese airspace
it suddenly drops off air
traffic control radar.
A modern commercial
airliner, carrying 239
people, has just vanished.
There's no mayday call and
no wreckage at the point
of last radar contact.
Aviation authorities
struggle to understand.
REPRESENTATIVE: We believe
family members should prepare
themselves for the worst.
(crying)
NARRATOR: Families left
behind demand answers.
WOMAN: (Speaking in Mandarin)
NARRATOR: The Malaysian
government launches an
investigation.
It will be the largest and most
expensive in aviation history.
With multiple dead ends, false
leads, a deluge of speculation,
but only a handful of real
clues.
One of the first comes from
the Malaysian military.
Powerful defence radar has
detected the plane, turning
back across Malaysia,
heading northwest up the Strait
of Malacca, then disappearing
out of range here,
just north of Sumatra.
It's a shocking discovery.
After it disappeared from
civilian radar, it didn't cras.
It continued flying.
JOHN: Initially when the
airplane made a turn without
talking to air traffic control,
in my mind, all bets were off.
It could be a terrorist event.
It could be a deliberate act
by a crew member,
it could be a mass failure
in the electrical system.
NARRATOR: The next
clue comes from space.
Although lost to radar, MH 370
continued to exchange what are
called 'heartbeat' signals
with an Inmarsat satellite
above the Indian Ocean.
The heartbeats
come once an hour.
Frequency changes in the
signals help experts calculate
its direction of travel
and reveal something
extraordinary.
After its initial track to the
northwest, MH370 turned south
and flew for six more hours.
From the travel time of each
signal investigators also
calculate the plane's distance
from the satellite.
These lines are called arcs.
Using the fuel load and cruisig
speed, they can recreate a rane
of possible flight paths
as the plane crosses each arc.
The final, or seventh, arc
is deep in the Indian Ocean.
There are no more heartbeat
signals beyond this point.
PETER: The data was
extraordinary in as much as
you're trying to establish
an aircraft's position based
on information that was never
intended for that purpose.
NARRATOR: It's the biggest
breakthrough so far
instantly shifting the search
3,000 miles south of the last
military radar contact
taking it into the jurisdiction
of the Australian government,
and accident investigator Peter
Foley.
PETER: This is something
extraordinary that was captured
by Inmarsat at the time
the aircraft was in the air,
which very few people knew about
and which is absolutely key
to the search and working out
where to look for that aircraft.
NARRATOR: They
start looking here:
a swathe of ocean running
seven hundred miles along
the seventh arc.
They estimate that the
plane could lie 140 miles
either side,
the maximum glide
range of a 777.
The seventh arc is over
1,500 miles from the
nearest land.
It will take two days
for Australian search
vessels to get there.
Two powerful storms have swept
through since MH 370 disappeard
making the job of spotting
debris even harder.
22 aircraft and 19 surface
vessels look for wreckage,
and possibly even survivors.
PETER: When an aircraft
enters the ocean with energy,
you expect to see a potential
oil slick;
you expect to see all
sorts of objects, actually,
which are buoyant,
which are released from
the aircraft as debris.
NARRATOR: Surface debris is
normally the first step to
finding a missing aircraft,
but it's not a guarantee.
Before MH370, the largest
and most expensive search in
aviation history takes place
here, 8,000 miles away in
the Atlantic Ocean
hunting for the wreck of
Air France flight 447.
What lessons lie amid
this tangled wreckage, for
those searching for MH370?
On June the 1ST, 2009,
Air France 447 leaves
Rio de Janeiro, Brazil,
carrying 216 passengers
and 12 crew to Paris.
Weather reports indicate
severe thunderstorms
along the flight path.
Three hours and 45 minutes
into the flight, as the
plane nears the equator,
its on-board computers send a
burst of emergency warnings
then falls silent.
Olivier Ferrante is in charge
of the French search team.
The warning signals
are his first clue.
OLIVIER: Some maintenance
messages, and an important
position message,
which was very useful
for our search.
NARRATOR: It is a deep and
remote stretch of ocean, but te
search team has every advantag.
A known flight path.
An accurate final position.
And then, surface debris
found within five days.
And yet, despite initial
optimism, it takes two
years, four expeditions,
and forty million dollars
to find the plane.
OLIVIER: Yes I remember
that moment when
we found the wreckage.
I was very careful, because
we've had false alerts before
and then it turned out to be
geology or not what
we were looking for.
NARRATOR: Why does
it take so long?
Using the data meticulously
collected by the search team,
combined with the latest
visualisation technology,
It is possible to
drain the Atlantic Ocean
revealing the hostile
world that faces every
deep-water search effort.
Immense water pressure.
Freezing cold, total darkness,
and hidden dangers everywhere.
Finally, at 12,800 feet
the shattered remains
of Air France 447.
Engines, wheel assemblies, and
other heavy items lie together
their twisted remains
a testament to the
force of the impact.
Smaller, lighter, objects
stretch along more than a
third of a mile of sea floor,
equivalent to ten
New York city blocks.
And a critical realization:
the seabed wreckage is nowhere
near the surface wreckage.
It's almost 24 miles away.
Investigators have wasted
years searching directly
underneath the surface debris
not realizing that ocean
currents have carried it far
away from the crash site.
The long and frustrating
search for the French
aircraft carries a warning.
Even with debris and an
accurate final position, when
a plane goes into deep water,
it's very hard to find.
A sobering thought for the
team searching for MH370.
OLIVIER: Air France was very
difficult with our area of
17,000 square kilometres.
But it's nothing compared
to the the surface that the
search teams have to for MH370.
It's much more difficult.
NARRATOR: In the southern
Indian Ocean, investigators lok
for surface debris for over two
weeks.
Even with the aid of
satellites, they find nothing.
JOHN: One of the greatest
initial mysteries and that has
transcended the entire
period of time that we have
been looking for this
airplane, where is the debris?
NARRATOR: With no debris
they need to find another
way to narrow the search.
So they focus on MH370's
'black box' data recorders.
Each has an underwater
locater beacon or ULB.
In water they emit an
electronic 'ping' with a
range of just over a mile.
Find the beacons and
you find the plane.
But time is running out.
PETER: Battery life on the
ULB's is only 30 days.
Although they do last
longer they fade out.
NARRATOR: By the time
specialist pinger locater
technology reaches the search
zone, there are just three
days of battery life left.
(music)
O'DELL: Steer 319.
OFFICER: Steer 319.
NARRATOR: Investigators have
only a few days to locate MH
370's black boxes,
before their locater
batteries run out.
Faced with a vast search
zone, they decide to focus
on commonly used air routes.
PETER: It was thought that if
the aircraft had been in
distress and was trying to make
to complete a flight for
example to Perth, there was
some recognized air routes.
NARRATOR: Australian navy
vessel Ocean Shield steams to
the point where the air route
to Perth intersects
the seventh arc.
The team looking for Air France
447 also used pinger locaters n
an attempt to discover the crah
site.
They begin listening
for signals within days of
the plane's disappearance.
OLIVIER: In most cases the
pinger locaters work, and that
was our assumption before
Air France 447.
NARRATOR: Ships scour
the search area for forty
days but hear nothing.
The hunters wonder:
are the locater beacons
lost, or destroyed?
Returning to the remarkable
drained seascape of the Air
France 447 wreckage reveals
the scale of the problem.
The sea floor here is 12,800
feet below the surface
deep in the mid-Atlantic ridge.
And here amid the wreckage,
nestling in the remains of the
tail plane, the black boxes,
one with its locater
beacon still attached.
A search ship passed directly
over here, but detected nothin.
The metal wreckage may have
blocked the signals, or they
could have been damaged
by the sheer force of the
impact.
OLIVIER: I think
they were unfortunately
damaged, at that stage.
NARRATOR: Investigators
listening for the MH370
black boxes can only hope
they'll have better luck.
They monitor the ocean
for fifteen days, using three
ships equipped with sensitive
listening technology,
and military aircraft
launching sonar buoys.
They do detect some
signals, but conclude it's
just random interference.
It's another disappointment.
But at this low point
there's a dramatic new lead.
A team from Curtin University
in Western Australia runs a
network of sensitive underwater
microphones called
hydrophones positioned all
around the Australian coast.
They're designed to monitor
earthquakes, Antarctic ice and
wildlife and, remarkably,
one of them has picked
up an unusual noise
1 hour and 14 minutes after
MH370's last communication
with the Inmarsat satellite.
ALEC: When we looked at the
data from that hydrophone we
found one signal that looked
as though it had interesting
characteristics.
NARRATOR: Is this the actual
sound of MH370's final moments?
Alec Duncan's team look for
other audio recordings,
so they can calculate a
geographical fix.
ALEC: One hydrophone does tell
you a certain amount about the
source of the signal,
so you can tell whether it's
a whale, you can tell whether
it's a snapping shrimp,
you can tell whether it's
just noise from the mooring,
but you can't tell direction.
NARRATOR: Fortunately, other
agencies are listening too,
(explosion sound)
for the sound of illegal nucler
tests
with technology that can
accurately pinpoint the source.
Just of the coast of Cape
Leeuwin in Western Australia
the Comprehensive Nuclear Test
Ban Treaty Organisation runs
a listening post specifically
designed to detect and locate
illegal nuclear tests.
The station has three
hydrophones set one and
a quarter miles apart.
They can determine the
direction of a sound to
within half a degree
and calculate the distance to
the source, over thousands of
miles.
And astonishingly, this network
has detected the exact noise
heard by the team from Curtin
University.
ALEC: The analysis of the data
from Cape Leeuwin told us that
that signal had come
from the northwest and gave us a
fairly accurate bearing
along which the source of the
signal must have been.
NARRATOR: It's a
tantalizing clue
and the sound does come from te
direction of the seventh arc.
But when the scientists crunch
the numbers, the source of the
sound is far to the northwest
so far beyond the current searh
area that it's considered not
worth further investigation.
ALEC: Our conclusion was that
he signal was most likely
to be of geological origin,
such as a small under sea
earthquake but we can't
completely rule out
the possibility that it
came from something to
do with the aircraft.
NARRATOR: Faced with a new
disappointment, the search team
moves to a different approach:
searching the sea floor
itself, using towed sleds
carrying sonar scanners.
It will be the largest
undersea hunt in history.
But before it can even start
there's a new problem.
This part of the Indian
Ocean has never been
surveyed in detail.
The sleds will be close to the
sea floor and no one knows
exactly what is down there.
PETER: We knew we'd be
operating vehicles very
close to the sea floor,
which necessitated knowledge of
what was down there and
so that we could avoid
collisions with terrain.
NARRATOR: The MH370 team need a
simple way to create a snapshot
of the sea floor across the vat
search area.
They find help in
an unexpected place.
(music)
The team hunting MH370 across
463,000 square miles of Indian
Ocean, face one big problem.
WALTER: More than 99 percent
of the sea floor area in this
region has not been covered by
ships with modern equipment,
satellite navigation,
multibeam echo sounding.
NARRATOR: Geophysicist Walter
Smith thinks he might be
able to fill in the blanks,
using satellites.
WALTER: The satellites actually
cannot see the bottom, they're
not seeing the ocean floor,
what they're doing is using
radar to measure variations
in the sea surface height.
NARRATOR: It's possible,
thanks to gravity.
Mountains on the sea
floor create their own
gravitational attraction.
Surrounding water is drawn
towards the mass, creating
measurable changes on the
surface.
WALTER: The smallest ones I can
resolve are a kilometre or less
in height and they move the sea
surface about 5 centimetres
and the satellite has
no problem resolving that.
NARRATOR: It doesn't have
the resolution to spot the
wreckage of an aircraft,
but it's enough to help create
a basic map of the sea floor
and identify hazards in the
MH370 search zone.
What does the data reveal?
Using the exact information
gathered by Walter Smith's team
it's possible to drain away
the Indian Ocean to show what
the ocean floor actually looks
like.
As the water flows away it
exposes a world no human
has ever seen before.
Dramatic cliffs, more
than twice the height of
the Empire State Building.
Fault lines plunging almost
20,000 feet deeper
than any canyon on land.
A volcano-dotted valley
running for a hundred miles.
Operating underwater scanning
vehicles in this terrain will
take a huge amount of skill
and luck.
Armed with their new map of
the sea floor, the search team
deploys the latest in subsea
technology.
Travelling deep underwater,
these towed sleds begin
to scan the sea floor.
And they will be guided by
a game-changing new clue.
It comes from further detailed
analysis of the final Inmarsat
signal from MH370.
Engineers crunch the numbers,
and discover something shockin.
In its final moments, the
plane descends rapidly, almost
certainly because after
seven and a half hours in the
air, it's run out of fuel.
Boeing engineers then simulate
what happens when a triple sevn
exhausts its fuel
making it possible for the firt
time to recreate the likely
final minutes of MH370's
mysterious flight.
The right engine
flames out first.
The autopilot compensates
for the imbalance with a
hard left turn.
Minutes later the second
engine flames out.
With no power, the autopilot
switches off, leaving MH370
in a long spiral decent.
(crashing sound)
In every Boeing simulation,
the crash site lies within
29 miles of the seventh arc.
These dramatic new insights
immediately reduce the size
of the search area,
from 463,000 square miles
to just 23,000.
But that's still three and a
half times the size of the
search area for Air France 447.
ANDY: This is a
massive search area.
It's magnitudes larger
than any previous search
I have ever worked on.
NARRATOR: Deep sea salvage
expert, Andy Sherrell analyses
all the data
that's being gathered
underwater.
ANDY: Oddly enough when
I first heard about
MH370's disappearance,
my wife was in labour
with our first child.
The news came on about the
disappearance of the flight
and my wife looked at me
and she said,
'well that's a job you are not
going to be involved with.'
NARRATOR: Andy has been
involved ever since.
Using his knowledge from six
previous investigations,
including a search for Amelia
Earhart's Lockheed Electra.
As soon as the underwater
scanning begins, it identifies
shapes that could be manmade.
ANDY: So when you are reviewing
the side scan sonar it comes
down in a waterfall display
and you can see the different
intensities of, you know
soft sand versus hard rock.
NARRATOR: Guided by the
scans, the team investigate
80 locations in detail
but find no trace of MH370.
Then in May 2015, the
sonar picks up something
new and exciting.
ANDY: It was a typical looking
debris field that definitely
warranted more investigation.
NARRATOR: The debris field
covers an area similar in size
to the wreckage of Air France
447.
Could this finally be
the remains of MH370?
PETER: Sonar paints a very good
picture of the sea floor,
and what you've got there but
it's not perfect. It's not good
enough to say with certainty
that a certain item might
be an aircraft debris field.
You actually have to
investigate with visual means.
NARRATOR: They launch an
autonomous underwater vehicle,
armed with state of the art
sensors, to take a closer look.
Using the actual data it
recorded that day, it's now
possible to drain away the watr
from over the site, revealing
the most hopeful discovery so
far in the hunt for MH370.
At one end a pile of chains.
Then a 23 foot long metal box
rusted machinery and finally
three metal anchors.
They've found a shipwreck, its
wooden hull long rotted away.
The site strewn with
coal, probably cargo,
on its final voyage.
They haven't found MH370, but
in these dark uncharted depths
they're casting light on
tragedies from a different age.
The investigators discover
three other wrecks
Including this iron
hulled sailing ship
upright on the seabed.
And a modern fishing
trawler, nets stretched
out across the sea floor
proving that their technology
can locate and retrieve objects
as small as a piece of coal.
After fifteen months of detaild
scanning, covering 23,000
square miles of sea floor,
there's still no sign
of the missing plane.
ANDY: We have a very high
confidence that we would have
detected the plane in that
search area.
So all of these factors gives us
really high confidence that the
airplane debris field is not in
that area.
NARRATOR: The investigation
continues, still guided by just
two key pieces of evidence:
the Inmarsat calculations
and Boeing's flight
performance data.
Then, suddenly, a third
line of inquiry brings
hope of a breakthrough.
On a remote island on the
other side of the Indian
Ocean, 3,000 miles
from the search area, a
piece of metal washes up on
a beach
and it looks like it comes from
an aircraft.
(music)
NARRATOR: In July
2015, a council worker
on Reunion Island,
a French territory in the
Indian Ocean, stumbles upon
an unusual object on a beach.
It's called a flaperon.
There is one on each wing of a
Boeing triple seven part of the
mechanism that makes it rise or
fall.
Boeing quickly confirms that
its serial number matches
that of the missing plane.
It's the first piece of
physical evidence that MH370
ended its flight in the ocean.
OFFICER: It is my hope that
this confirmation will at least
bring certainty to the families
and loved ones.
NARRATOR: The suffering of the
families attracts the attention
of amateur wreck hunter
Blaine Gibson and sets him off
on a remarkable personal quest.
BLAINE: I was very, very
touched, very moved and realized
that I needed to go do
what I could to solve this and
what I learned, what that niche
was,
was that there was no official
search for debris that washed
ashore.
NARRATOR: Blaine consults
ocean drift experts, who
direct him to Mozambique
where he makes an
immediate discovery.
BLAINE: It was a triangular
grey shaped piece of debris
that said 'no step' on it.
Clearly aircraft.
I felt an enormous sense of
responsibility because I
realised that I had just found
the second piece of debris
in the greatest aviation
mystery in history.
NARRATOR: Boeing confirms
that the "no step"
debris is from MH370.
Blaine has found it 4,350 miles
away from the main search zone.
Still acting alone, he
continues to search.
BLAINE: We just found on Raike
Beach this piece of debris.
We have not picked it up yet.
NARRATOR: Almost thirty pieces
of debris thought to come from
MH370 are recovered.
All on the western side
of the Indian Ocean.
Blaine Gibson finds
fifteen of them.
One piece stands
out from the rest.
BLAINE: The most
significant to me, and
also to the investigation,
was the case around the
TV screen on the back of
the seat in front of you.
This is the one that
brought tears to my eyes.
This is perhaps the last
thing that somebody saw.
This is what anyone who flies
on a plane would recognize.
NARRATOR: Debris like this, frm
inside the passenger cabin,
confirms that MH370 hit
the water hard.
PETER: Some of the items
indicates that there was quite
a large amount of energy
at the time the aircraft
entered the water.
NARRATOR: Another
piece of debris helps
resolve a key question.
Investigators already believe
the plane ran out of fuel.
But as it fell towards the
ocean, was someone trying to
save it with a controlled ditc?
PETER: This section of main
flap was found in Tanzania,
Pemba Island in 2016 and
when imagery was passed to
us we realized it was
pretty significant.
NARRATOR: The flap extends on
an internal support track.
Investigators discover that
the track has left impact
marks inside the flap.
That can only happen if it is
in a retracted position strong
evidence that the plane was
in its normal cruising state
as it fell towards the sea.
PETER: It's been the
subject of a lot of debate.
The hard physical evidence
and our analysis showed that
it wasn't a controlled ditch,
or there wasn't active control
from the cockpit extending the
flaps at the time
the flaps separated from the
aircraft.
NARRATOR: The flap supports
the theory that the plane ran
out of fuel and suggests that
no one at that point was trying
to ditch or save it.
But the debris doesn't only
confirm how MH370 crashed.
It opens up a new and
exciting line of enquiry that
could narrow the search area.
DAVID: I think it's enormously
important to find the plane,
because while planes crash
routinely,
they don't just disappear and
I think this terrifies people.
NARRATOR: Oceanographer David
Griffin believes that the very
first piece of debris recovere,
the flaperon on Reunion
Island, may be the key.
SKIPPER: This'd be a
good spot, I reckon.
The wind's probably a
bit stronger, I guess. Yep.
DAVID: This is a Boeing
777 flaperon off another
aircraft, not MH370.
SKIPPER: We use this anchor
to sink it again, alright?
NARRATOR: David Griffin is
trying to recreate the journey
of the flaperon across the
ocean,
in the hope this will
pinpoint the crash site.
He compares the flaperon's
movement to these buoys.
Known as ocean drifters, they'e
used daily all around the world
to monitor ocean currents.
DAVID: We very quickly
determined that these replica
flaperons moved about
10 centimetres per second
faster downwind than an
oceanographic drifter.
NARRATOR: That may not sound
like much, but when he compares
it to known data about
the currents in the seventh arc
on the day of the crash it hels
him estimate the flaperon's
travels during the 500
days it was afloat.
It's an extraordinary discover.
To narrow the search zone
even, further David Griffin
investigates
another strange feature of the
debris.
DAVID: In addition to
knowing where things
are found in Africa,
the other key thing is
where things have not been
found and that's Australia.
NARRATOR: Why has no debris
been washed ashore in Australi?
Some of the ocean currents
in the search area flow
east towards the country.
A plane crashing here
should leave evidence
on Australian beaches.
DAVID: So this immediately
tells us that all those
potential parts
of the seventh arc, where the
flow is strongly towards
Australia,
they're essentially ruled out.
NARRATOR: When David Griffin
looks at the historic drifter
data from the day MH370
disappeared he finds three
places on the seventh arc where
the current would have pushed
debris away from
Australia towards Africa.
DAVID: Here around 35, you have
this area where everything is
moving to the west.
Again up at 31, everything's
NARRATOR: If the plane crashed
in one of these areas, it would
explain why debris was not foud
in Australia.
And critically, only one of
these locations matches his
calculation of the flaperon's
journey.
DAVID: So that led us to
propose that 35 south is the
most likely area for the crash.
NARRATOR: 35 south is an area
that was not checked during the
initial surface debris search.
For investigators, it's
an exciting new lead.
But it comes too late.
MINISTER: It is with some level
of sadness, certainly with a
great deal of frustration
and disappointment that I stand
here and acknowledge that the
search,
the underwater search area
effort, has been suspended.
NARRATOR: On January the
17th 2017, after almost
three frustrating years,
the search for MH
370 is called off.
ANDY: Obviously I had strong
feelings and am disappointed
that we didn't find he aircraft
but it's not for the technical
abilities or the giving it full
effort and feeling good about
the job that we did at the time.
PETER: It was record breaking
in terms of the time it took
and the area that was covered.
There's never been a search as
big by an order of magnitude.
NARRATOR: But will David
Griffin's flaperon experiment
persuade authorities
to search 35 degrees south?
It takes almost a year
to answer that question, and
new evidence from the skies.
(music)
Oceanographer David
Griffin has a new theory.
He thinks MH370 is in
an area called 35 south.
And in 2017, he finds
more evidence pointing
to the same place.
DAVID: I remember the day when
I first saw those images in high
resolution and I thought my God,
this, this really helps.
NARRATOR: Fifteen days after
MH 370 disappeared, a French
military satellite captured
images of possible
manmade debris in the
vicinity of 35 south.
At that time, the location
wasn't considered a high
priority area.
But, four years later,
it's a different story.
DAVID: And I thought that
this is really exciting.
This could be used to
restart the search.
NARRATOR: A new year
brings new hope.
In January 2018, salvage compay
Ocean Infinity sets out on a
brand new, privately funded,
mission.
The seventh arc is
still the focus.
But they expand the width of te
previous search zone and move
towards the new area
identified by David Griffin.
Once again, Andy Sherrell is
on board and this time he has
eight autonomous underwater
vehicles or AUVs.
ANDY: One deep towed vessel
would do a swing of about thiry
days on site and over those
thirty days on sight they would
cover about 35 hundred square
kilometres.
Using eight AUVs simultaneously
we can cover that in about
three to four days.
NARRATOR: It's a
high stakes gamble.
If they find nothing,
they don't get paid.
Ocean Infinity searches the
new priority area at 35 south.
In five months they cover an
area almost equal in size to
the original sea floor search.
But frustratingly, they
find no trace of MH370.
The two search efforts
have covered almost 92,000
square miles of sea floor
fourteen times the size of the
Air France 447 search zone.
(music)
In May 2018 the Malaysian
government announces that
it will not support any new
searches.
OFFICIAL: We cannot keep on
searching for this 370 forever.
NARRATOR: Is the wreckage of
MH370 waiting to be discovered
in the 386, 000 square miles
of seventh arc search zone
that remains unexplored?
Do clues to the mystery lie a
few feet outside the circle of
light and knowledge already cat
by the search teams?
Only time, money and the
continued desire for answers
separate us from the moment
of discovery.
But the knowledge, hard
won over two search
efforts and four years,
will be invaluable
for any future hunt.
Using the extraordinary
data gathered by hundreds
of investigators,
we can drain the area around te
seventh arc to reveal what MH30
might look like
when it is found.
The debris will stretch out
over thousands of yards.
The engines will
be in one piece, the
fuselage in thousands.
The nearby black boxes
will reveal if anyone was
in the cockpit at the end.
Emergency oxygen cylinders
may show if the plane
depressurized in flight,
whether intentionally or
the result of an accident.
And personal electronic devices
could reveal the experiences ad
fate of individual passengers
and crew.
It will be a profound moment,
one that Andy Sherrell has
experienced before.
ANDY: It's a really surreal,
kind of sombre moment because
you realise all of a sudden
that you have found this you,
gravesite, this place where
all these people perished.
It's sad but it's also a bit of
relief because you know that
from that point forward
some answers are going to come
back.
OLIVIER: I think you have to
be to remain optimistic,
and if you don't search,
you don't find.
So hopefully at the end
you will find it.